So if you've been watching this channel for a little while, you probably know that i am a big fan of cheese
and I've actually been starting to make my own this year
I figure if people like beer and they brew they're own beer, and if people like wine and they brew they're own wine
Why can't I make my own cheese?
Milk is one of those things where it's kind of weird
(Laughs)
it's a really weird byproduct that we eat
like it's... animal juice
if you ever wonder how cheese is made
this is how its made
(Rhythmic music)
That white stuff in milk is basically bits of fat proteins and regular proteins.
They are suspended in a liquid.
Usually it's pasteurized, meaning its boiled so there's no pathogens in it.
And the next thing they do to it is they homogenize it
which is basically where they take all those fat particles
mix it all up so its evenly distributed throughout the milk.
The thing is that breaks down those fat molecules, gok but bad for cheese.
You want nice, robust, fatty...globs
in your milk because all those globs -
you're basically gonna seperate that from your liquid
and those globs impact together and dry out
and that's how you make cheese.
So we wanted to give you guys an update on what's going on with studio four
because it is coming together really nicely.
So let me take you around and show you what they've done.
Guillermo and the boys have been working hard
starting up here.
They've brought the sheetrock all the way in and buttoned in this window.
There was a gap in between the original skylight was and where the new skylights fit.
So that's gonna look really nice when it's done
As you can see these beams are in pretty bad shape.
They need to be sanded, they're super dusty.
So the guys are gonna go through, they're gonna get a rotary sander,
they're gonna come all the way across here
making this nice and smooth, and then they're gonna make it pop
with some beautiful color.
We got rid of that old, horrible air conditioner
that was about 30 years old and probably had some cancerous materials in it.
It really makes the height of the unit pop out
Guillermo's done a really good job with this renovation so far.
I think he's got another 2 and a half more weeks to go.
It's a big day, it's a big thing for us.
I've dreamed about days with insulation and air conditioning.
What I'm going to do today is I'm going to take this big gallon of milk and make brie.
Now the process is basically the same for other types of cheese.
Today I have raw milk.
This milk has not been pasteurized, it has not been homogenized.
It is straight up raw milk from the cow.
It's actually kind of hard to find.
It cost me 17 dollars and 50 cents
but it tastes creamier and it's more rich, more robust
and if I'm gonna sit around and spend hours making my own cheese, why not go the extra mile, right?
First things first, Carmichael you wanna see what raw milk tastes like?
fat stuck to the top of it
If I shook this all up you'd start getting butter.
Taste it.
So good.
I grew up, having german milk with my grandparents.
It's like so close the texture and the taste
of my German childhood.
(laughing)
The things you need to make cheese:
2 buckets of water, or bowls
regular water for rinsing stuff off
water with Iodine to keep it sterile
the pot that I washed off
I'm going to simply put the milk in.
Now you have to bring the milk up to a specific temperature.
In this case, 90 degrees Fahrenheit (32 degrees celsius)
That temperature activates the bacteria
and the mold and promotes growth.
Alright, we're gonna leave that, and let the milk warm up.
Our milk is at the right temperature
and we're gonna put in the bacteria culture.
Pure bacteria.
Aromatic mesophilic -
and you can buy this stuff a bunch of different places online.
Different cheeses use different bacterias.
Now, put in the penicillium camemberti,
and this is a mold culture.
And this is what's going to grow that white mold.
Stir it in.
Nice and evenly distributed through the milk.
Let it now sit for 15 minutes.
There's a lot of new players in the market for subscription digital services,
and we've gotten a few offers to pitch things
So I'm gonna take you guys through that process of
what's required when you're pitching a new show to a new client.
(Drum music)
Every great idea can be boiled down to two things.
A great name, and a one-sentence description of everything you need to know.
I came up with this idea called "Country Ops"
What does that mean? Well, it's a show about Corridor teaming up with the
most experienced special operations veterans in the world to test
their field skills in an all-for-fun "redneck" type game scenario.
This simple description and title is what we would call an "elevator pitch".
It's called an elevator pitch because you've gotta be able to
tell it to somebody that you don't know in an elevator.
If they don't understand what you're talking about...
you blew it, kid.
After you go through your description, you want to tell the reader
a little bit more about what they're getting themselves into.
On my scenarios page, I list out game type scenarios
that give a little bit more context to what each episode would be like.
Demolition derbies
ATV football
Lawnmower racing
What's not to love?
Even more important than what you write in a pitch document
is what you show the viewer.
So you gotta include things in there
that are simple and easily convey your
message.
Next, I move on to my format page, where I convey
how the show is presented to the audience.
Now, when someone's going out and spending
a bunch of money on a show, they want to make sure that
eyeballs end up on that project.
They aren't able to go and talk to everybody and get
to know everybody, so you gotta show 'em numbers.
So here, for example, I've shown what our audience demographics are,
what our geographical demographics are,
what we're known for online,
and what kind of connections we have that can help get this series done.
At the end of the day, everything you do boils down
to trust and credibility.
And so our reach page just helps emphasize that, in fact,
we do know what we're doing, and we've done this before.
Last thing you want to hit them with a little zinger that
calls back to the title of the show.
Here, I used our phrase, "See you in country."
This gives them a memorable way on how they're gonna
sell your great idea.
When it's all said and done, don't be afraid, and let your idea fly into the world!
No! Nooo! My papers!
No!
Good cheese takes a long time.
I wanted to make Gruyère because that's uh...
the cheese used in fondue, and I really like fondue.
It's kind of expensive, too.
So like "I'll just look up how to make it".
It takes about a year. (laughs)
So now we're gonna put in the rennet,
and rennet is an enzyme that's going to cause the
curd to separate from the whey.
I'm going to take one of these rennet pills, basically, they're just a capsule,
dissolve it in some water.
Now the thing is, you can't use tap water for that
because tap water has chlorine,
and chlorine will kill your bacteria cultures.
It's the same thing with salt. Salt usually has Iodine in it,
and at the end, we're going to salt the outside of the cheese
to keep other molds from growing.
But, if you use salt with iodine,
it can also kill all the bacteria.
(Tink)
Stir.
Give it a little shake.
And this is going to now start reacting with the milk.
Like, for example, you take your blood. You have blood cells,
but your blood cells are suspended in your blood plasma.
So we're effectively separating the blood cells from the blood plasma.
You take those blood cells and pack them into a little cylinder
where they turn into cheese. (laughs)
After just turning it over in the mold for a couple hours
and letting the liquid drain out,
take the solidified block of milk fat now.
I'll put salt on the outside,
and then put it in the fridge, and that's it.
That's the extent of work. That's all it takes to make cheese.
You grab your milk, mix new bacteria, you mold
the rennet to make it solidify,
and you walk away, more or less.
There's the whole "putting it in the mold" thing, but it's really
not a big deal. Like, making cheese is
really, really easy. I was surprised at how easy it was.
It just takes time.
Yeah, that's it. I guess we'll have another cheese party in a couple weeks.
(Laughing)